[Music]  this is what islam is  why isn't everybody muslim  that are actually diminishing the  violence if you can kind of you know  share and expound on that that'd be  really interesting not living to satisfy  my desires but living to satisfy the  commandments of allah  that was the biggest challenge for me  i called the local masjid and the imam  invited me over and said if this is what  you believe this is what you have to do  we made my shahada and we've been  learning ever since thank you guys for  coming out here thank you brothers for  traveling the long distance to be here  with us you know thank you lord you are  in the beginning there was nothing but  allah not a single soul younger nothing  but allah  you